[Musique]
françaises français au cours de ce
premier entretien vous attendez sans
doute de moi que je vous dise pourquoi
je suis candidat à la présidence de la
république et aussi qui je suis votre
attente est d'autant plus justifiée que
je suis celui dont on a évité de vous
parler avant la proclamation officielle
de ma candidature par le conseil
constitutionnel
je suis en effet celui qui ne respecte
pas la règle du jeu
institué par les parties et que vous
aviez quelques raisons de croire
définitivement périmés françaises et
français le 27 avril dernier dans votre
majorité vous avait signifié aux
responsables de la politique à tous les
responsables votre immense espoir de
renouveau en déposant votre bulletin
dans l'urne ce jour là vous avez dit il
faut que ça change
avez-vous vraiment l'impression que
leurs responsables ont l'intention de
répondre à cette espérance que vous avez
formulées vous allez voir défiler
pendant quelques jours sur les écrans de
vos postes de télévision les différents
candidats et vous allez constater bien
vite que le choix qui vous est offert
n'est pas celui qui peut répondre à
votre attente que vous proposons en
effet d'un côté l'homme qui pendant six
ans a été le principal responsable de la
politique à laquelle vous avez dit non
le 27 avril
de l'autre les hommes des parties
responsables de la politique
à laquelle vous avez dit non en 1958 est
ce cela le renouveau est il possible de
choisir le prochain président de la
république que parmi les fantômes de la
5e et les heureusement de la quatrième
française français cette constatation
douloureuse que vous êtes amené à faire
aujourd'hui un seul était à l'origine de
ma candidature
les centaines d'élus locaux qui ont
cautionné ma candidature
on considérait que je pouvais être
l'homme qui tournant le dos à un passé
révolu incarnerait une véritable
ouverture vers l'avenir
pourquoi parce que je suis comme des
millions d'entre vous un homme qui
chaque jour dans ses activités
professionnelles subi l'inhumaine
dictature des bureaucrates et constatent
les méfaits des lois que nous impose une
technocratie hélas toute puissante parce
que je suis un homme libre
tolérant respectueux de toutes les
opinions et de toutes les croyances
mais qui pense au plus profond de lui
même que la véritable grandeur et dans
la recherche du mieux-être pour le plus
grand nombre qui croient que la
véritable grandeur et dans une politique
de bonheur qui croit qu'il est temps de
rendre la joie de vivre aux français en
les libérant de l'oppression d'une
administration qui trop souvent a perdu
le sens du service public
je dis bien l'administration et non pas
les fonctionnaires qui sont mieux placés
que quiconque pour savoir que la
véritable révolution des temps modernes
sera celle qui renoir les liens rompus
par la technocratie dans ces états
majors parisiens entre l'administration
et le peuple
j'ai accepté de répondre à cet appel
et de poser ma candidature parce que cet
acte de foi dans la liberté et la
justice pour tous répondez à l'action
que j'ai mené toute ma vie je suis un
homme du peuple
mon père était savetier dans un petit
village du pas de calais grâce au
sacrifice de mes parents j'ai pu
poursuivre mes études et obtenir à 19
ans mon diplôme d'ingénieur des travaux
publics
j'ai d'abord travaillé pour les autres
j'ai fini par créer ma propre entreprise
j ai acquis le sens des responsabilités
et cette expérience sans lesquels je
n'aurais jamais accepté de me présenter
aujourd'hui à vos suffrages
comme beaucoup d'entre vous j'ai fait la
guerre
je suis le tenant colonel de réserve
dans l'infanterie et officier de la
légion d'honneur pendant les années
noires de l'occupation allemande
j'ai rejoint les forces françaises de
l'intérieur
j'ai occupé des postes importants dans
la résistance
j'ai participé au combat contre l'ennemi
et je suis titulaire de la médaille de
la résistance
je suis donc de ceux qui n'ont pas
attendu septembre 44 pour reconnaître ce
que le pays devait taux général de
gaulle
même si par la suite je n'ai pu accepter
une politique faite en son nom et dont
chacun d'entre vous ont pu juger dans sa
vie quotidienne
les conséquences j'ai été pendant 20 ans
élu municipal et j'étais vice-président
du conseil municipal de paris et vice
président du conseil général de la seine
je me présente à vous comme un libéral
je ne suis pas un conservateur
je crois que chaque matin apporte à
l'homme public l'occasion de nouvelles
batailles à livrer pour le bonheur de
ses contemporains l'occasion d'un nouvel
engagement
la direction d'un grand pays comme la
france exige à la tête de l'état un
homme libéré des dogmes et des
disciplines des appareils de parti
c'est seulement ainsi qu'il peut être le
véritable arbitre que vous attendez
c'est seulement dans la mesure où le
président de république de demain ne
sera pas le prisonnier des chapelles et
des sectes politique qu'il pourra
appeler au gouvernement
l'équipe républicaine comprenant les
hommes les plus qualifiés pour redresser
notre économie et faire face à la
situation monétaire devant laquelle nous
nous trouvons aujourd'hui et qui est
grave vous le savez et ses hommes
qualifiés
il faudra non seulement les choisir dans
les différentes familles spirituelles
mais aussi parmi les représentants des
groupes socioprofessionnels ou leurs
compétences se sont affirmés contre la
dictature des technocrates contre une
information dirigée contre les atteintes
aux libertés communales contre une
politique de logement absurde quand le
carcan dirigiste quand la force
participation contre le sort fait aux
rapatriés aux expropriés contre l'eau
précise tva contre la dépréciation
déprise agricole contre le sort fait aux
commerçants artisans pme contre la crise
universitaire compte la sous
représentation des organisations
professionnelles
quand la coûteuse est illusoire
politique de prêt steve compte les
contradictions de la politique étrangère
poursuivi ces dernières années vous
venez d'exprimer votre refus mais
pouvez-vous sérieusement penser que ceux
qui viennent
aujourd'hui vous faire de belles
promesses seront capables d'accomplir
demain ce qu'ils ont été incapables de
réussir hier pouvez vous un seul instant
crois que pour ouvrir les portes d'un
avenir plus juste plus humain plus
heureux vous devez vous adresser aux
hommes d'hier ou à ceux d'avant pierre
il n'en est pas un sage de se contrôler
quels je me présente aujourd'hui
auxquels la france n'est pas dit non
d'une façon catégorie à celui ci elle
l'a dit le 27 avril dernier
à cela elle l'a dit en 1958 devant les
échéances tragique qui nouvel accès à
ces autres elle a signifié en juin
dernier lorsqu'il est exploité à des
fins partisanes
le mouvement spontané de la jeunesse je
suis ainsi celui qui viennent m'en
voulait ma propre libre de passer avec
le peuple de france
un contrat sincère et loyal françaises
français
je suis présent dans cette élection
présidentielle certes pour vous
permettre de faire respecter le choix
que le peuple de france a fait le 27
avril dernier
comme beaucoup d'entre vous hommes et
femmes de toutes conditions
j'entends que l'état désormais soit au
service de la collectivité nationale et
se préoccupe de réaliser pour chacun et
pour 12 des conditions de vie meilleures
je sais que vous êtes très nombreux à
partager mes sentiments
j'aime les citoyennes et des citoyens
qui accomplit chaque jour
honnêtement leurs devoirs et quelles que
soient leurs opinions religieuses
philosophiques ou politiques
j'entends les servir avec passion je
respecte les hommes d'état qui mettent
leurs connaissances et leur expérience
au service de la nation je nord et je
considère les hommes politiques qui
gagnent leur vie en faisant leur métier
et qui en plus pour servir leur idéal
consacrent leurs efforts à la gestion
des affaires publiques
ils font ainsi bénéficier leurs
concitoyens de l'expérience qu'ils ont
acquise
dans les luttes de la vie mais j'avais
prise comme vous ceux qui viennent de la
politique qui vivent de la politique et
surtout ceux qui n'ayant pu réussir leur
vie prétendent mener les affaires du
pays c'est ainsi que je me présente à
vous aujourd'hui
j'aspire à être un président citoyens à
l'image des sites ce pays j'aspire à
être un véritable arbitre seulement
soucieux d'apporter la liberté et la
justice pour tous
après tant d'expériences douloureuses
vous êtes en droit d'exiger françaises
français je fais confiance à votre
jugement il ya votre sagesse ensemble
vous et moi nous allons montrer un
professionnel de la politique que
quelque chose va changer en france
[Musique]